in your in your like uh opinion or
perspective how do you think like Japan
itself has like changed in like the past
10 years do do you feel like anything
very vague question sou is in like have
you noticed any changes in like the past
10 years in any anything anything in
Japan and 10 years well well I I just
thought about a Twitter becoming expit
it's not really in Japan Twitter is more
popular in Japan than in the states
though oh really yeah it is I think more
people use Twitter okay okay yeah in 10
ear well the streaming is not well are
these like twitch wise and twitch is
still not in not known in Japan that
much it's crazy because some of the
biggest TW uh streamers on Twitch are
Japanese I know well I think especially
like a vtubers they stream mainly on
YouTube and yeah and the streaming
culture or the Tipping culture or
supporting the streamer Financial
culture is not there in Japan yeah it's
still rooted in like the Nik n ER could
they buy a lot of merch though right I
think so yeah like they probably come to
meet in greed and support like in person
it's more about meeting in person
because Japan is well it's like smaller
like it's like it's a big country but
you know easier to side is Big yeah side
is like small and yeah I guess it's more
of meeting the person and there are a
lot of like a Gamers who've been like
watching with so many viewers but like
almost like a zero sub so that I guess
like a streaming cou might be like so
different in Japan I see a lot of
vtubers advertised just very small Indie
vtubers just advertised everywhere I
just be passing a bar and they'll be
like this is our vtuber mascot for the
bar and I'm like what the hell because
there now there's like a billion vtuber
agencies you know whereas like 10 years
ago there was maybe like one maybe two
that were like kind of notable but even
then it's like now it's just like oh do
you want to be famous on the internet be
a vtuber well I guess cuz everyone
thinks that it's probably easy to make
money but I think being an agent
it's actually really hard to make money
well it's also I think just driven by
the fact that you know I think the
majority of people who do want to like
start streaming in Japan you know a lot
of them don't want to reveal what they
look like or you know their name or
anything like that so like the most
common route for that would just be Ving
you know which makes a lot of sense but
at the same time now all these agencies
are aware of that and so they're just
going to start exploiting the [__] out
of these people who don't know any
better yeah so that's one thing that's
changed I guess higher rate of
exploitation the one thing that's really
unique about um V2 bear and the agency
damic is that now at least when you were
a solo person and you were a part of an
agency they couldn't own you they can
own you now which is like the best thing
that's ever happened for agencies ever
and the worst thing that's ever happened
for yeah the fact that you can just own
this character and all their socials and
everything is like I don't think people
understand how [__] awful this is for
creators and people who make things or
any artist out there this is terrible
ter this is awful awful for all you
don't have ownership for anything but
your voice yeah which is crazy and even
that like they you know the fact that
you can have the voice but you can be
deplatformed and lose everything it's
like
okay it's like you're the mask singer
but when you get taken off they don't
rip your mask off they just kick you off
stage it's like actually no you never
get to find out who it was uh yeah maybe
maybe he'll be on Twitter somewhere else
yeah find out I'm I'm just I'm just
waiting for like the time when they just
get like an AI program to replace your
voice after you decide to quit and just
like zombie you this 100% going to
happen I mean they already try to keep
kizna ey alive from the dead yeah like
with 15 attempts they were like please
which which hul experiment will work
let's find another voice actor and I
figure it out it's like if anyone
doesn't think this is going to be abused
at some point I think they're just dumb
yeah definitely at some point some
agency is going to figure it out and
some point it'll work it'll work at some
point yeah did you see K and I actually
made like or her agency made an anime as
well and was it was it was awful really
wow wait was it like was it an anime
around kids in the eye or was just
completely separate no it was it was an
anime around they made like a kind of
like a vtuber agency anime oh is it like
this year anime like original
anime something yeah yeah and uh so so I
thought he had a lot a lot of potential
like an anime based around a vtuber
agency around like training V
made by V agency you know I thought
there was so many different directions
this could go I forgot I forgot what the
name of it is but it just turned out to
be like a normal ass Idol anime where
people they they just made another Idol
anime and the best looking part of that
show was when K I made like a twom
minute Cameo uh two minute just two
minutes okay just a two minute Cameo
entire in the in the entire show wow
yeah damn um but I'm surprised like he
here here's like here's like the uh five
head move I thought they were going to
do I thought they were going to make an
anime showing off these like new
characters introducing them to this like
Idol show and then debut them you know
that would have been a smart decision
that would have the smartest we just
have like at this time a below another
below average Idol anime least of the
world yeah did you like ID anime at all
oh yes I am actually I voicing this new
anime but it's it's gonna be in January
oh yes and then actually it's the show
in sodio it's like a monk what's that
monk time it's going to go monk time
it's like it's like Snot for monk time
like it's like a different show but
they're all based on TL or BL or kind of
like ich manga right right um well I am
like one of the main girls and actually
I've been not just voice but also doing
the Ste song and
work too yeah I'm doing like a
Valentine's Day like chocolate like
handing out event too at book in
February but so that's like a proper
idol God damn but the thing about those
show like sometimes you can see like
they're going to be on TV but they show
the first part or the know etchy part on
TV and if you want to see more
subscription side or buy the Blu-ray
yeah breay DD and for AER sometime they
replace the voice actors because some
vas are but they are too mainstream and
they don't want to risk their reputation
carea or sometime they have like a
different name and show up for ity part
but I guess you know I don't care so
that's I I can get like been there done
that good I can show my safe face you
know well I've noticed the line of fort
ety in anime has been pushed more and
more every year to the point where I'm
like what is the difference between
anime and like or ety anime and hentai
now and true yeah I mean seeing
something like redo of heiler I'm like
this line is obliterated there is no
line this this is just straight up him
that's why it was insane to watch I was
like okay I knew cuz like I knew a lot
of these scenes beforehand cuz I read
the light novel beforehand so I was like
I was waiting for it and then I guess
what I had watched originally was the
like the TV sensored version right so
when I watched episode 2 I was like why
is it just slowly panning on a fireplace
for 15 minutes only the wall yeah like
what's happening and then I found out
about it I was like all right let's
actually check this out and I I knew
what was coming up I didn't actually
think they were going to do it though
you know even though this is like the
streaming Blu-ray version I was like oh
this is just this is just hentai now
it's crazy that the the audacity for
them to be like yes this is an anime I'm
like no it's not I know I think in some
ways it was like worse than some of the
henai I've seen as well you know it's it
it went in hard like it it it it pulled
no punches I will never forget that dick
slap scene I will I will that is
ingrained into my mind for I could watch
all the [__] up haai in the world but
the one that will always stick out to me
is that [__] dick slap in the face
have you seen that on Twitter like
somebody with dick fighting I don't know
for the content or like thing oh the uh
the dick fight island is that what it's
called no it's actually people live
action not anime actual actual people
and what wait like [__] fighting yeah
[__] fighting yeah it's not Japanese it
was I don't know if it when when or yeah
where it was filmed but wait wait you're
going have to explain this you you were
just on Twitter one day and you saw two
naked dudes just hitting dicks yeah like
not two there were like so many I guess
like those are the final it's like a
battle royale yeah it's like a dancing
competition and Street dancing
competition and other like Po losers
were just chanting like go go go and it
was you have to wait show me this this a
fever
dreaming what I think yeah crotch
fighting oh my you have to press it you
press it it's on it's like centr oh yeah
Comedy Central show float like a
butterfly sting like a penis that's the
long and short of it the game is simple
it's the best of five rounds the fighter
with the most hits wins and the winner
is chub Norris it's like a joke it's
like a it's a joke okay okay okay okay
oh okay it's a skit but on Twitter you
don't know like if it's real or not so
like is it happening cuz how can you
stay hard like know when yeah you were
singing this going to be on Netflix or
yeah I guess you if you're straight o
Gat that's going to be like a reement
right so it's like wow what's going I
kind of want to watch
this like the under under like 21 they
got the they got the gay category yeah
they have to they have to otherwise it's
unfair right otherwise it's unfair like
legs yeah my referee just checking and
if they're not in under
there that's actually kind of funny D
they got to make that a real show now I
would watch it I'm surprised that he
isn't already yeah right that was a very
random
thing that's the thing of Twitter random
keep coming up J Twitter is [__] Twitter
recommendations be like no here's some
CCTV footage you didn't ask for I get
that every [__] morning I look at
Twitter it's just like I don't I'm not
even following this account why why
getting these I I don't want to watch a
dude getting hit by a car at 8 in the
morning that's just not how I want to
start the day what it's horrible what
are
you dude there's this [__] there's
there's multiple accounts I get I don't
follow any of them right but every time
I'm on I'm on Twitter in the morning I'm
like I just want to see like what my
friends are up to this morning and I
check first thing or first or second
thing that always comes up is this just
like these [__] accounts that have
these like CCTV footage it's literally
just like Lively light that's
essentially what it is it's and it's
just like oh yes a man narrowly escapes
getting hit by a train and I'm just like
cool but I just woke up I don't I don't
want to watch any of this my T is just a
mix between news and boobs so it's like
like it's like one one news so opposite
yeah it's horrible because I'll be
scrolling and I'm like man this news
nothing between news so boobs yeah well
it's man I think that's Twitter mostly I
see like news it be super depressing
like 10 people die and then you scroll
down you're like Bo [__] you're like can
I see more news please Mom just like
controversial takes boobs controversial
takes about anime boobs anime boobs yeah
yeah
yeah always it's always the anime boobs
because I follow Joey that's the reason
why nice